welcome to Hannity tonight yes we are
live from the swamp the sewer that is
Washington DC tonight I can report the
sky is absolutely falling we are all
doomed the end is near the apocalypse is
imminent and you're going to all die all
of you in the next 48 hours and it's all
president Trump's fault or at least
that's what the media mob and the
Democratic extreme radical socialist
party would like you to think they are
now sadly politicizing and actually
weaponizing an infectious disease and
what is basically just the latest effort
to bludgeon President Trump how many on
the left and now all but Rudy for Corona
to wreak havoc in the United States why
to score cheap repulsive political
points now should we you know let's look
at this seriously absolutely we have an
obligation this is who we are as an as a
people to do everything possible to keep
every single American and frankly
everyone worldwide safe and healthy this
is who we are as Americans this is what
we do we pray for the sick we do pray
for the families that have lost loved
ones absolutely that's also who we are
as a people now we all want to cure for
AIDS cancer heart disease and every
other disease and every other affliction
and we have with our American doctors
and researchers we have led the entire
world and we have literally shared all
of our discoveries all of our cures with
the entire world because that's who we
are as a people but tonight the
fear-mongering is off the charts now you
have some on the left literally whipping
this country into a frenzy
some promoting extreme measures
immediately close schools immediately
daycare centers businesses mass transit
systems and the cancellation of any
large gathering now if things do get
dramatically worse it may come to that
we are nowhere near that point as of
tonight thankfully however according to
the mob and the media well your life is
about to be horrible and it's all Donald
Trump's fault one New York Times opinion
columnist actually doesn't New York
Times called the coronavirus the Trump
virus writing if you're feeling awful
you
you know who to blame did Donald Trump
create this in a lab somewhere now
another article in The New York Times
complaining that Trump has a problem
with the corona virus threatens the u.s.
his credibility fake news CNN's official
Hannity stalker known as Humpty Dumpty
got very melodramatic tweeting out quote
since the dawn of the Trump era
countless experts have warned that the
president's lack of credibility would
imperil the country in the event of an
emergency as the corona virus outbreak
worsens those fears may be coming true
Humpty relax it's just quivering with
fear with his stalker assistant Oliver
somebody and he's a stalker you see
what's happening here they seem to be
hoping for panic chaos mass panic
devastation and even an economic
catastrophe oh if it's bad for Trump
it's probably gonna be good politically
for us is that the thinking here they
seem to be giddy Wall Street's decline
Wall Street is always skittish do they
really care about our health your
well-being your family's well-being do
they care about your 401ks do they care
about the truth by the way what have
they done the last three years except
hate Donald Trump every second every
minute every hour of every 24-hour day
week month that's what they do but
anyway you be the judge take a look
Donald Trump's predecessors understood
when the nation felt fear if it was
around a shooting a death a national
catastrophe they had an empathy Donald
Trump refuses to recognize that fear and
there's going to be a growing chasm
between what Donald Trump and Mike Pence
have to say about coronavirus and what
the American people feel about it I
regret having to say this but we all
know that President Trump in the course
of his service has disrespected science
and scientists has told an awful lot of
untruths I can just reminder Japan the
Prime Minister there just asked all
public schools to shut down for a month
that's how serious it is there imagine
if that happening well also a reminder
today has been a game changer this is
that puts there's a proposal now that is
meager anemic for words describe the
administration's response to the
coronavirus towering and dangerous
incompetence they have let a good
tragedy or virus go to waste
remember according to the mob and I've
been telling you this for Democrats and
the media mom if the dog bites at the
bee stings if you're feeling sad it's
all president Trump's fault how many
times on this show of I said if
President Donald J Trump cured cancer
tomorrow the left would want to impeach
him for that because he might have
consulted with a Russian or Ukrainian
scientist the same people wouldn't even
find one good word to say
now one when Iran's top terrorists
Soleimani was taken out and by President
Trump and now we're seeing the same
brand of petty politics look if we can't
get the left to unite and immediately
unite on killing a masked terrorist who
killed hundreds of our fellow citizens
of Americans if we can't unite work
together to keep our country safe from
illness and disease and a virus
there's nothing will ever agree on many
top Democrats are now spreading the
light the president Trump recklessly cut
the budget for the NIH and the CDC well
hate to tell you that is a lie according
to even the AP in their fact check the
funding is actually increased under the
president but why let the truth get in
the way of an opportunity to bludgeon
Trump
make no mistake put on a virus it is
dangerous those infected are contagious
before they show symptoms during the
incubation period you don't know they
have the disease the rapid spread of the
virus across continents it is of course
concerning the president he has been
taking it seriously from day one
way back in January way before the
Democrats seem to care at all about the
corona virus the White House declared a
public health emergency then you might
recall the president barred non-us
citizens who recently visited from China
from entering the United States wow
that's something the left and the mob
would say is bigoted he's been on top of
this fully engaged from day one all
Americans returning from China were
subject to extensive screenings and
quarter
teens again something the left wouldn't
do and to date thankfully zero people in
the United States of America have died
from the corona virus zero now let's put
this into perspective in 2017 sixty one
thousand people in this country died
from influenza the flu common flu and
around a hundred people die every single
day from car wrecks of course it's
tragic but despite what you hear the
world is not coming to an end
of course it's serious and as the
disease continues to spread the
president has requested billions of
dollars in additional funding he has
appointed the vice president to lead the
response the vice president is calling
on all Americans all Americans to work
together to combat this infectious
disease Democrats the media mob they're
having none of that instead they're more
interested in launching vile vicious
personal attacks for cheap political
points self-appointed science expert
remember that congresswoman who
predicted the world is going to end in
12 years alexandria Castillo Cortes
tweeted out quote Mike Pence literally
does not believe in science it is
utterly irresponsible to put him in
charge of the coronavirus responses the
world sits at the cusp of a pandemic
this decision could cost people their
lives okay and then she has her
socialist pal yep Bolshevik Bernie
Sanders also launched into a deranged
tirade he wrote quote by picking a vice
president Mike Pence to lead the
administration's response to the
pandemic Trump has not only chosen
someone completely unqualified but the
president has made clear he's more
concerned about his own politics than
the health and safety of the country
basically say the president wants you
all to die we can only assume that all
of this and the following statements
will be praising communist dictatorships
around the world for stomping out the
disease from their socialist hellholes
you know the ones that kill people
innocent people and steal their property
and sadly the kind of political vitriol
well that continued on TV and we've got
the video evidence let's go to the
videotape is that the person you want in
charge
of weather of the corona virus outbreak
someone who needs to prey on something
instead of looking at the science why is
Mike Pence in charge what is his plan to
stop the virus abstinence because he
insisted that Mike Pence can help make
all of these various departments of
government work which would be true
if Mike Pence is actually good at that
and we're not aware of any evidence that
indicates that and coming up vice
president Pence he will join us tonight
for an exclusive one-on-one interview he
will respond to these attacks discuss
the very latest details on how the
administration is aggressively
responding to Corona but it's clear the
left psychosis their rage is now
reaching new depths of depravity you're
so desperate to reclaim their power and
250 days destroy President Trump they
are treating a deadly virus like a
political weapon a tool it's shameful
behavior shouldn't surprise us at all
we've watched and witnessed the last
three years but it does hurt the country
does nothing to stop the spread of
Corona a perfect example this comes from
Elizabeth Warren her plan for battling
Corona is to stop construction of quote
Trump's racist border wall that'll work
these people are not well let's be
honest here they don't have good
intentions what have they done the last
three years to keep us safe and secure
and create prosperity and jobs for the
American people
nothing except hate the president they
don't have any good plans they don't
have any good ideas they don't have any
strong candidates all they do is rage
towards the president it is a
bloodthirsty lust for power and it's
really ugly
and sick and dangerous